Mein Name ist Mischa Janiec.
Ich bin 27 Jahre alt.
Ich bin Natural Bodybuilder
und Online-Unternehmer.
Täglich
verfolgen über 500'000 Leute
meinen Weg in den sozialen Medien.
Mein Motto ist:
jeden Tag ein Stück besser werden.
Ich stehe hier
vor dem Mekka of Bodybuilding:
vor dem Gold's Gym in Venice,
wo eine Legende trainiert hat:
Arnold Schwarzenegger himself.
Er ist eine grosse Inspiration
für mich.
Heute trainieren wir
mit einem sehr bekannten Natural
Bodybuilder, mit Simeon Panda.
Ich glaube, er ist das bekannteste
Gesicht in diesem Sport,
in dieser Szene. Er hat
auf Instagram über 4 Mio. Follower.
Da siehst du,
wie gross diese Szene schon ist.
You look massive!
Yeah!
* Popmusik *
Ich wollte einfach mal wissen,
wie er trainiert.
Die Leute sagen,
ich hätte einen krassen Rücken.
Aber sieht man seinen Rücken,
denkt man: "Das ist nicht möglich!"
Ich dachte,
er könne mir noch Tipps geben.
Auch nach neun Jahren
geht immer noch mehr.
Du kannst immer noch versuchen,
besser zu werden.
Die Leute limitieren sich und sagen,
es gebe ein genetisches Limit.
Dieses sei nach zwei
oder zehn Jahren erreicht.
Ich glaube, es ist erst erreicht,
wenn du sagst, es sei erreicht,
wenn du mit dir selbst
abgeschlossen hast und sagst:
"Das ist es gewesen.
Ich werde nicht mehr besser."
Dann wirst du
auch nicht mehr besser.
Aber gehst du mit dem Mindset rein:
"Es geht noch was!", wieso nicht?
Daher musst du dir immer Leute
suchen, die besser sind als du.
120 kg ... Mehr, 125 kg!
Das habe ich noch nie gemacht.
Let's do this!
Look at that!
Nice!
* Popmusik *
* Stöhnen *
Ich muss eigentlich auch
in die Cam gucken.
Ja, gerne!
Wir versuchen gerade, ein geeignetes
Thumbnail fürs Video zu finden.
Das ist das Bild,
das man auf YouTube sieht.
Wenn das möglichst optimiert,
möglichst klickgeil ist,
kann das zehnmal mehr Klicks
ausmachen.
* Popmusik *
Ah!
Uh!
Ja, ja, genau!
Ja, das ist gut!
Alles, was du nicht filmst,
ist nicht dokumentiert.
Das ist wie bei der Geschichte:
Alles, was wir heutzutage wissen,
wissen wir,
weil es irgendjemand
aufgeschrieben hat.
Die Bibel beispielsweise:
Die Sachen mit Jesus wissen wir nur,
weil sie jemand aufgeschrieben hat.
Filmen wir es nicht,
wird es nur in unserem Hirn bleiben.
Das ist auch schön,
aber will man es teilen,
muss man es dokumentieren.
Darum filmen wir es.
Bodybuilding steht noch immer
in einem negativen Licht.
Es ist
ein sehr oberflächlicher Sport.
Aber ich finde,
wenn man die Tendenz dazu hat,
sich mit sich selbst
zu beschäftigen ...
Du reflektierst dich
ja auch im Spiegel,
wenn du trainierst.
Das reflektiert auch in die Seele.
Ich habe gemerkt:
Du kannst so viel an dir verbessern,
was über deinen Körper hinausgeht.
Ich will den Leuten mehr geben
als nur zu zeigen,
wie man ein Sixpack
oder dicken Bizeps bekommt.
* Popmusik *
Wir sind gestern
von Hawaii zurückgekommen.
Vor 8, 9 Std. sind wir eingeflogen.
So!
Mhm, ja!
Er schmeckt so wie jeden Tag.
Kaffee ist für mich auch wichtig.
Das ist ein Ritual.
Wenn ich schon nonstop
unterwegs bin,
will ich wenigstens am Morgen
ein Ritual haben,
das ich überall machen kann -
egal, ob ich mal
in der Zeitzone von Hawaii bin.
Jetzt sind wir hier.
Es ist 11 Uhr.
Eigentlich wäre erst 7 Uhr.
Aber meinen Kaffee trinke ich
einfach immer nach dem Aufstehen.
In der ersten Stunde nach
dem Aufstehen kommt mein Kaffee.
So habe ich wenigstens etwas
in meinem Alltag, das konstant ist.
Einer meiner biggest steps
letztes oder dieses Jahr war es,
die Schweiz zu verlassen,
weil ich
in den letzten beiden Jahren
keine zwei Monate mehr
in der Schweiz war.
Ich nütze die Infrastruktur
in der Schweiz nicht mehr,
habe aber dennoch noch zwei Jahre
brav meine Steuern bezahlt.
Dieses Jahr habe ich gesagt:
"Das mache ich nicht mehr."
Ich war staatenlos.
Ich habe mich beraten lassen.
Nachher
meldete ich mich in Panama an.
Da spare ich
natürlich sehr viele Steuern.
* Rockmusik *
Ich habe immer eine Regel:
Wenn ich nicht mindestens zehn Tage
an einem Ort bleibe,
packe ich gar nicht aus.
Man könnte das
"Digital Nomade" nennen.
Das hat vielleicht schon mal jemand
gehört: der digitale Nomade.
D.h., Thailand und Südafrika
z.B. für die günstigen sechs Monate,
in denen man Geld spart,
wenn man so will,
weil man in der Schweiz
viel mehr ausgibt als in Thailand.
Und dann komme ich hierher
und gebe das Achtfache aus -
also doppelt so viel, wie ich
in der Schweiz ausgeben würde.
Ich kann es mir aber auch leisten,
weil ich sechs Monate im Jahr
in günstigen Regionen lebe.
Wenn ich zurückblicke,
bin ich in den letzten drei Jahren
in 25 bis 30 verschiedenen Ländern
und in etwa 60 Cities gewesen.
Es wirkt von aussen schon so:
Was geht da ab?
Der einzige Grund,
dass ich mir das leisten kann,
ist natürlich, weil ich meine Skills
so weit ausgebildet habe,
dass sie schwer von jemand anderem
zu kopieren sind.
D.h., ich habe mir
erst mal einen Skill angeeignet,
der eben über dieses normale
Fitnesstrainer-Niveau hinausgeht.
Ich habe begonnen, mich wissen-
schaftlich damit auseinanderzusetzen
und habe natürlich auch gesehen,
dass dieser Skill sehr gefragt war.
Ich bin in diese Szene
hineingewachsen.
Und gleichzeitig ist das Medium,
über das ich das Ganze
transportiert habe,
also die sozialen Medien,
auch im richtigen Moment explodiert.
Das ist der Leverage,
den ich damit kreiert habe,
dass ich nicht im Gym bin
und eine Person trainiere,
sondern einen Onlinekurs mache,
den in den ersten beiden Jahren
über 4'000 Leute gekauft haben.
Jetzt, in den letzten beiden Jahren,
sind nochmals 3'000 bis 4'000
dazugekommen.
D.h., ich habe mittlerweile
über 8'000 Leute,
die meine Programme gemacht haben.
Und diese verkaufe ich im Schnitt
für 150 Fr. bis 250 Fr.
* Popmusik *
Uh!
Als ich bei Orange arbeitete,
erklärten mich die Leute
für verrückt.
"Was? Du kündigst deine Stelle?"
Mein Lohn war nicht schlecht.
"Und das nur für YouTube-Videos?
Wie willst du denn Geld verdienen?"
Sie begriffen das damals nicht.
Heute sagen dieselben Leute:
"Mischa, du hattest Glück!"
* Popmusik *
Momentan reist Marcel mit uns.
Marcel filmt mich halt nonstop.
Wenn ich ins Gym oder essen gehe
oder ein Storyvideo drehe,
filmt er, schneidet den Film
und lädt ihn auf YouTube hoch.
D.h., ich habe viel weniger zu tun.
Wenn du im Leben
wirklich weiterkommen willst,
musst du deine Zeit definitiv
als wertvoll betrachten -
wertvoller als Geld - und sie
nur noch ganz gezielt einsetzen.
D.h., ich schaue,
dass ich Leute wie Marcel dabeihabe,
dass ich Online-Assistants habe -
ich habe drei,
die gewisse Sachen
für mich übernehmen.
So kann ich morgens aufstehen
und erst einmal lesen.
So kann ich auch täglich
meine 2 Std. im Gym haben.
So kann ich mich auch
mit Leuten treffen
und Geschäftsmeetings machen,
was ich auch sehr wichtig finde.
Und gleichzeitig kann ich auch
ein guter Boyfriend bleiben,
denn sonst ist man
ein überarbeiteter Workaholic.
Und das will ich gar nicht sein.
Ich finde, das ist einer
meiner wichtigsten Faktoren,
was Selbstoptimierung betrifft,
denn in dem Moment,
in dem du
aus dem Hamsterrad ausbrichst ...
Für gewisse Leute ist das Hamsterrad
eine Karriereleiter.
Aber wenn man aussteigt
und es sich von der Seite ansieht,
sieht man,
dass es sich im Kreis dreht.
Du kannst als CEO
oder Vice president
noch so viel Geld verdienen -
du wirst es nie ausgeben können.
Du wirst nie wirklich
diesen Spass haben können.
Und wenn du in das Alter kommst,
in dem es so weit wäre,
ist die Frage,
ob du das noch willst.
* Popmusik *
The third to the left.
- The third to the left, okay!
Hello!
- Hi there! Mischa?
Yes.
Okay, go ahead!
Go ahead! Lie here on your back!
And then lie yourself
on that middle line!
DEXA-Scan.
D.h., du scannst den ganzen Körper
und bekommst nachher
gewisse Angaben zu deinem Körper,
z.B. Körperfett, Knochendichte.
Ich habe z.B. Skoliose.
Da ist für mich interessant:
Kommt meine linke Seite mit meiner
rechten nach, wenn ich trainiere?
Das jetzige Ergebnis ist auch
für die Muskelmasse interessant.
Hat sich etwas getan?
Das ist natürlich jedes Mal
die Hoffnung.
Ich weiss,
dass sich etwas getan hat,
aber ich will es
auch noch auf dem Papier haben.
Wow!
Das sind 2 kg in einem Jahr.
Vegan.
Vegan 2,5 kg Muskeln aufgebaut.
Juhu!
* Popmusik *
Ich habe jetzt einen Call
mit David Goldman.
Das ist ein Facharzt
fürs Thema Lebensverlängerung.
Life Extension.
Das ist sehr interessant.
* Popmusik *
Bye-bye!
No, but you know what I mean.
- Yeah, I know what you mean.
In den ersten vier, fünf Jahren war
das Einzige, was mich interessierte,
wie ich noch muskulöser werden kann.
Jetzt geht es mir eher darum:
Wie kann ich noch gesünder werden?
Wie kann ich meinen Alltag
um dieses ganze Ding aufbauen?
Dadurch,
dass ich jetzt auch reise ...
Ich habe ja schon
die bewusste Entscheidung getroffen,
dass das nicht mehr mein Leben ist,
sonst wäre ich in meiner Wohnung
in der Schweiz,
würde meine fünf Mahlzeiten pro Tag
kochen
und täglich im David Gym trainieren
- no pain, no gain.
Das habe ich abgeschafft.
Darum versuche ich jetzt,
immer noch das Optimum
herauszuholen,
aber es ist definitiv
nicht mehr alles in meinem Leben.
Nein, sie hat recht: Es ist wichtig.
Wenn ich an einen Ort fliege
und mehr als eine Woche dortbleibe,
muss es ein gutes Gym geben,
sonst habe ich ein Problem.
* Popmusik *
Ich selber konsumiere am Feierabend
manchmal Marihuana.
* Popmusik *
Man muss schon sagen:
Jeder Wirkstoff -
Koffein, Marihuana, Alkohol ...
Es gibt Leute, die diese Wirkstoffe
besser vertragen,
und Leute,
die sie nicht so gut vertragen.
Daher ist Cannabis für viele Leute
typenabhängig keine gute Option.
Und Alkohol hat das Problem -
nicht für jeden, aber für mich -,
dass er sehr viele Kalorien enthält.
Viele Leute sind sich nicht bewusst,
dass Alkohol pro Gramm
sieben Kilokalorien hat.
Das ist fast so viel wie Fett.
Selbstoptimierung heisst für mich,
nicht allem fernzubleiben,
sondern alles mal auszuprobieren
und herauszufinden:
Ist das etwas für mich?
Bringt es mich weiter?
Wie wenn man ein Videogame
und einen Joystick hat:
Du drückst mal alle Knöpfe
und schaust, was passiert.
Und wenn du deine Knöpfe in den
richtigen Momenten bewusst einsetzt,
kann dich das sehr weit bringen.
* Popmusik *
Perfektion ist ein Ziel,
das sich jederzeit wegbewegt.
Sobald du an dem Punkt bist, an dem
du gedacht hast, es sei perfekt,
wirst du realisieren,
dass es nicht perfekt ist.
D.h., einer Perfektion nachzueifern,
ist sehr gefährlich
und kann dazu führen,
dass du dich an einem
unglücklichen Ort wiederfindest.
* Popmusik *
Ich selber habe die Challenge,
meine Glücklichkeit zu behalten.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass es
mehr oder weniger Glück gibt.
Glück ist ein Status.
Es ist ein Moment.
Und weil man Glück
eben meistens innen findet,
finde ich es eben auch
ein sehr gutes Ziel,
einfach weiterhin glücklich zu sein.